pages from a trump tax return sent to
the new york it's one of american
politics
biggest secrets how much taxes donald
trump paid
and to whom does his company owe money
few of the numbers have ever been made
public
he's missing financial figures a big
issue in 2016.
maybe he doesn't want the american
people all of you watching tonight
to know that he's paid nothing in
federal taxes
so that makes me smarter nearly four
years on
the president's financial secrets have
ended up in the supreme court
and it has delivered a limited victory
to trump with a ruling that means his
money
likely won't be a major issue this
election season
the court case pitted the trump empire
against congress and prosecutors
democrats wanted access to company
records
trump's lawyers argued the opposition
wanted to harass
not oversee the administration
the court found nancy pelosi wanted too
many documents
but it didn't dismiss the speaker's
request outright
including the president the path that
the supreme court has laid out
is one that is clearly achievable by us
in the lower court and we will continue
to go down that path
but the court's decision isn't an
overwhelming win for the president
because the supreme court also says his
financial records
must be turned over to new york state
prosecutors
which could mean he could face charges
in the future
from a certain point satisfied from
another point i'm not satisfied because
frankly
this is a political witch hunt the likes
of which nobody's ever seen before it's
a pure witch hunt it's a hoax
analysts say the court's ruling is a
draw for the president
one that leaves the supreme court above
the political fray
as the u.s faces a bruising election
season
for more on today's rulings i'm joined
tonight by scott anderson scott has
served as a legal advisor at the u.s
state department
he's now with the brookings institution
and teaches law at
georgetown university law school scott
is in washington d.c tonight
welcome to the dave scott it's good to
have you with us the court today
said that the president is not above the
law when we're talking about the justice
system and gathering
evidence what does this ruling these two
rules what do they say about the
american justice system
and what did they tell us about the
current u.s president
well they certainly serve as noted
victories although in some ways limited
victories for the rule of law
and it's important that you think of the
two opinions separately the vance
opinion
related to a subpoena against the
president or for the president's
financial records i should say
uh to a bank by the state of new york
and the court essentially affirmed that
the state of new york can proceed with
that subpoena is entitled to that
information that the president doesn't
have any special protection by virtue of
being president
to prevent that information being
disclosed that's going to allow the
state of new york to continue in doing
criminal investigations
and other investigations the same way
would against other business leaders but
it's not going to lead
to the disclosure of that information
becoming public
simply because there's still a grand
jury process and other protections to
disclosure the information
that the state of new york has indicated
that it intends to respect
the second case the masar's case was by
several committees in congress and in
that case
the supreme court came back and said
contrary to what the president was
arguing yes there are in fact
a range of cases in which congress can
subpoena this sort of information about
the president from third parties banks
and his accountant in this case
uh and that that is not such a high
standard that the court argued to make
it uh that apparently that the president
argued to make it essentially impossible
in fact
there's a variety of situations where
the congress may be able to do this
but it also said it still implicates the
separation of powers and it's important
that congress and the courts
weigh the different factors uh regarding
congress's interests and the executive
branch's interests and reach an
accommodation or a balance between them
and so it remanded those requests to the
lower courts to re-examine those factors
as it felt
they had not done so adequately scott
today
the u.s president tweeted his outrage um
over these rulings and
he he said that other presidents have
enjoyed broad
deference by the courts but not him
what does he mean by that and is that
true
it's not clear entirely what he means
deference is usually a sort of term we
associate with other sorts of legal
questions not really implicated here
in this case we have seen presidents uh
be forced to comply with criminal
investigations
such as happened to president nixon and
request for information there we've seen
presidents have to comply with civil
investigation as happened with president
clinton in regards to
paula jones and certainly the vance case
at least is very much
consistent with those uh the masar's
case regarding congressional requests is
a bit of a new novel question at least
as confronted by the courts in this case
but again it confirms what most people
expected uh which
is generally consistent with the law as
it's understood in the united states
which is that congress has a substantial
authority to request this sort of
information
perhaps with some limits in extreme
cases but still substantial authority
and this affirmed that that was again
something that the president was arguing
against
now we know based on today's rulings
that new york prosecutors
they will probably ask to see the tax
returns and see those tax returns now if
these documents if they become evidence
in a criminal investigation
and if there is enough here to issue an
indictment
what happens to donald trump if he's
reelected president
and what happens to donald trump if he
is not reelected and becomes private
citizen donald trump
certainly if he becomes a private
citizen it's a likely scenario that we
will see
uh the president have to answer those
charges in the same way that any other
private citizen would at that point
the separation of powers concerns and
other concerns regarding
uh the pres the impact on the president
his conduct of this role
and his ability to exercise his function
as president
being hampered by any sort of litigation
or criminal defense likely isn't going
to be implicated
if he remains in office and the
president is no doubtedly going to argue
that as long as i'm in office
the fact that this criminal
investigation is going to severely
hamper my activities as president
means that i shouldn't have to face
these charges at least so long as i'm in
office
and that if the united states or if the
u.s institutions want me to face these
charges
congress can impeach me and then it
becomes a question as to whether
really congress is going to be willing
to take that step to remove him from
office and force him to confront those
charges or whether there may be some
other
uh legal uh uh avenue by which the
president may be held accountable
that is this fact pattern that we
haven't really encountered before in
this
in this case so squarely about a
president being criminally prosecuted by
a state
and it raises a range of novel legal
questions um but all of which are
highly problematic including for the
president let me ask you this about the
legality of a deal
before leaving the the white house scott
there has been talk that if the
president were to leave let's say if
there were to be another impeachment
trial that maybe he would resign
and he would resign only with a deal to
have immunity after leaving
the the white house would that be legal
is there any president in u.s history
for something like that happening
uh that's an interesting fact pattern
that i have not actually heard directly
before
in terms of resigning and trading away
the office of the presidency that would
be a pretty exceptional thing for the
state of new york to demand in
regard to the masters case or for
congress to demand in regards to
these subpoenas which again are just
requesting information i find it hard to
believe that that would
actually be a condition that either
party would
put forward or seek out in those sorts
of negotiations if the president wants
to resign to reduce scrutiny on him he
certainly can do so
he may resign and then seek a pardon
from his vice president who would then
be president and get the part in power
in the case of mike pence that's a
possibility at least that was discussed
in
the context of richard nixon did happen
in richard nixon's case i should say of
course president ford then pardoned
nixon after he left office
but again it's not clear whether pence
would play along with that here it
certainly would raise certain eyebrows
so i don't know how seriously i would
take any of those concerns at this point
particularly because not many of these
matters are likely to come to fruition
before the november elections
almost all of them are going to come to
fruition afterwards yeah that's a very
good point
um we want to remind our viewers scott
about the the controversy over
trump's tax returns trump says that his
taxes are still being audited it's been
a long
period for the audit four years ago
before the election
i spoke with nick jackson he's one of
the only journalists to ever interview
donald trump about
his taxes and this is what jackson said
in july 2016 about trump not wanting to
release his tax returns
one of the things i wanted to i was
looking for because i'm an expert in tax
havens i was looking for donald trump
um using tax havens and i asked him a
couple of times about this
and he said he said you know i don't use
tax havens
because you can get everything you need
in the united states and you may doubt
his words i mean he says a lot of things
that people don't believe but i
i think speaking to a lot of tax tax
experts in the states they did find that
plausible
um because it is just so easy to get
right down to zero you just don't need
to use them and he told me you know
they're complicated nobody knows what's
going on tax havens are kind of
difficult things to
to use and you know it is plausible his
new line of business
is um licensing so his name right
licensing his name
yes so he will get um somebody will will
say you know we're going to build a
building in india or saudi arabia or
something like that and we want to put
the trump name on the top and he'll say
yes you can do that and you pay me
you know a few million franchises it's
like a franchise yeah and so he's doing
that all over the place and he he told
me he's
he's got 121 of these licensing deals in
the pipeline
um we'll wait and see what comes out
it's all the money he's getting then
from these overseas
licensed uh buyers is that money then
coming directly into the u.s i mean
because that's a great chance for
for him or for anyone to keep it
offshore exactly i mean
that was one of the things one of the
sort of hypotheses i looked at and
i think um there's no evidence that he's
doing any of that in in
in a very aggressive way no evidence
that i could find that he's keeping that
offshore and it was you know there were
tax advisers who said
he could be doing that we won't we can't
see it because his tax affair is a
secret he hasn't released his tax
returns
those tax returns would answer these
questions right
so that was the state of play four years
ago not a lot has changed
there but we know the president may be
trying to avoid more than just
tax troubles scott nancy pelosi today
saying
congress has not finished investigating
the president the court today the
supreme court it did not say that
congress has no right to see trump's tax
returns the court had a problem with
how congress had tried to obtain those
returns
is that correct to some extent
it may be more proper to say that the
supreme court had a problem with how the
lower courts evaluated congress requests
essentially the lower court said hey
these are requests to banks and
accountants not to the president
themselves so they don't really
implicate major separation of powers
concerns
regarding the executive branch and the
legislative branch we don't need to
evaluate those concerns the supreme
court came today and said
no you actually do even though this to a
third party it can
affect the executive branch's interest
and you need to look at them more
closely
and therefore going to remand and for it
to you and force you to take another
closer look
bearing in mind a list of factors they
sort of identified
so it doesn't mean that congress can't
get these files at all if anything i
would read the opinion is suggesting
they can in certain circumstances
but it did indicate there are strong
countervailing interests in the
executive branch
that the lower courts and congress need
to take into account and it
sent the matter back to the lower courts
to make sure that they are taken into
account
scott anderson with the brookings
institution helping us to understand
these rulings today coming up from the
supreme court scott we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you
thank you
you